Okay guys, so welcome back to the desk.
That was a huge and important part of the
PTM video series.
So what did we learn? Well, we learned and
got resources for portfolio modeling,
portfolio volatility, portfolio
correlation and calculating beta.
You've got the downloads, use them
properly and regularly. So you're going to
be using the downloads on a regular basis.
Modeling portfolios, you're going to be
modeling portfolios, current and intended.
So if you have current portfolios, you'll
be modeling them. If you want intended
portfolios, you'll be modeling them too.
And if you want to make changes to your
portfolios, you're going to model the
changes.
You'll be using it on a regular basis.
You'll also be calculating portfolio
volatility and correlation on a regular
basis.
Okay, these resources are going to be
extremely useful for you going forward.
So portfolio volatility, like portfolio
modeling, again, current and intended
portfolios and when you're making
potential changes to your portfolio.
Calculating beta, that's important as
well.
You're going to be calculating the beta of
individual stocks and you're going to be
calculating portfolio beta on a regular
basis for, again, both current and
intended portfolios.
So these are great resources, guys.
You're going to be using them all the time
going forward.
They're going to save you and make you, if
you use them on a regular basis and you
use them properly, they're going to save
you and make you a ton of money over your
trading career.
So, guys, we're going to go through a
recap now.
So, let's go through everything for
foundations of portfolio management.
Let's go to the screen.
Okay, so welcome back to the screen.
Obviously, that was a hell of a lot of
information to take in over the last four
videos with Christopher Quill.
But what we're going to do here is
something very useful.
I'm going to recap everything for you so
you get a full understanding of all the
concepts that have been taught in the last
four videos by Chris.
And how you can use or how you should be
using all of the spreadsheets that are
available in the downloads area.
So, what have we looked at in the previous
four videos?
Well, Chris Quill covered the four key
components of foundations of portfolio
management.
We covered these areas at this stage so
you can get a clearer picture on why we do
things the way we do things.
So, the reasons why professional traders
do things the way we do things as we move
into the trade idea generation processes
in the next part of the PTM video series.
Additionally, it also provided a welcome
break from the rigorous processes of
top-down and what we're moving on to next,
bottom-up analysis.
So, the four areas that Chris Quill looked
at were portfolio modeling, portfolio
volatility, portfolio volatility and
correlation and how they connect, and
calculating beta.
So, what we're going to do is we're going
to go through each part, summarize all of
the key areas and how everything fits
together and how you should be using these
sheets moving forward.
So, let's start with portfolio modeling.
What did Chris show you?
Well, firstly, he showed you how to
download stock price data from publicly
available sources.
What does that mean?
Well, it just means that you don't need to
subscribe to any software at all.
You can do all of this yourself.
All of the data is publicly available as
long as you know how to get that data, how
to get the correct data, and how to
process it.
You do not need to buy software.
You're going to save a ton of money doing
this.
Granted, it's a slower way of doing it.
But when you're starting out, it's very,
very important to do this process to
understand the nuts and bolts of your
business, to understand data, know where
to get it.
You can rely on yourself and engage in all
of the processes with the data to get to
your own answers and conclusions.
Secondly, Chris showed you various methods
of how to compare historical performance.
So, specifically, indexing methods and
calculating a time series of performance.
And there were two ways that he showed us
how to do that.
There was the constantly equally weighted
method, so the CEW method for calculating
portfolio performance.
And there was the non-rebalanced portfolio
method.
And initially, in Chris's teaching
methods, he started off with a two-stock
example.
So, starting you off with a simple example
of two stocks using both methods.
So, for the constantly equally weighted
portfolio performance method, with the
two-stock example, what is it actually
useful for?
Well, it's helpful for monitoring whether
one stock is just outperforming another or
not over a period of time.
Now, although this is impractical in
day-to-day use, since it requires a
rebalancing every day,
the method does give us the cleanest and
quickest way of monitoring outperformance
versus underperformance of just one stock
versus another.
A more practical and applicable method
that Chris showed you was the
non-rebalanced portfolio.
And in the two-stock example, what was it
useful for?
Well, it's useful for just backtesting a
two-stock portfolio performance on a
dollar basis.
So, a long versus short two-stock
portfolio, but over a certain time period,
a long and hold versus short and hold
strategy and not rebalancing the positions
every day.
So, this is a more practical method than
the CEW method.
But, of course, and as Chris showed, both
methods are important and it's important
to utilize both methods and to compare
results.
When you get quick at these processes, you
can very easily and very quickly utilize
both methods, the CEW portfolio
performance balancing method and the
non-rebalanced portfolio method for two
stocks to analyze the actual performance
of genuine spread trades in practice.
And then, what do many spread trades
become?
So, what Chris showed you next is the
application of both methods, the CEW and
the non-rebalanced method when we're
calculating portfolio performance.
So, the most useful and practical method
for portfolio modeling is the
non-rebalanced portfolio method,
how is it useful?
How is it useful?
Well, when we're engaging in our processes
on a regular basis, it's useful for us
prior to doing a number of things.
So, prior to building an actual long-short
stock portfolio, it's also useful before
we even think about adding or taking out
long or short positions to an existing
portfolio.
So, remodeling a portfolio, it's also
useful before we decide or consider on
increasing and decreasing our dollar
exposures to certain longs or shorts in an
existing portfolio,
or even one that's under consideration, or
even one that's under consideration, and
it's also useful for us to analyze the
potential drawdowns of specific
portfolios.
So, based on past performance, what were
the drawdowns in a specific portfolio?
What can we expect in the future?
So, we're also looking at risk as well as
opportunity.
When we're modeling a multi-stock
portfolio and we're using the constant
equally weighted, the CEW portfolio
method, we have to assume that the weights
always stay the same throughout the date
parameters that we've chosen.
So, although impractical and not as
practical as the non-rebalanced portfolio
method, because it requires a rebalancing
every day, the method, similar to the
two-stock example, does give us the
cleanest and quickest way of just
monitoring outperformance versus
underperformance of a bunch of stocks that
were long,
and a bunch of stocks that were short, or
indeed, a bunch of stocks that we're
thinking of going long versus a bunch of
stocks that we're thinking of going short.
So, going forward, in terms of portfolio
modeling, you will be engaging in both
processes as they are both useful.
But what will happen over time is that
you'll end up focusing more on the
non-rebalanced portfolio method simply
because it's more practical on an ongoing
basis for real money trading and portfolio
positioning.
But you have to remember, guys, and as
Chris pointed out, this is all
statistical, rigorous processing.
What you really need to worry about,
because we are in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon, is your trade ideas.
It's just being long, great stocks that
are going up and great shorts that are
going down in our chosen time period.
There is a bigger picture to this.
We're looking at past data.
So, yes, we're getting an appreciation of
historical performance.
But if we totally ignore our trade ideas
and we only focus on statistical rigor,
what's going to happen?
We're going to end up with bad trade ideas
that we're putting into competent
statistical rigor.
And the outcome of that is that we're just
probably going to lose money over time.
So, you have to have both.
You need to worry about your trade ideas
being as high quality as possible.
And you need to engage in your statistical
processes to understand the historical
performance of portfolios that you're
running.
And also what the performance is likely to
be or the historical performance from the
past when you're making changes in your
portfolios.
So, you will be engaging in these
processes, but never forget trade ideas,
obviously.
The spreadsheets are useful because you
can model portfolios in the past.
And you're doing it to get a sense of
historical performance of a current
portfolio or an intended portfolio.
Now, something else that Chris looked at.
He also looked at the differences in
portfolio performance based on market
capitalization dynamics.
So, he looked at two model portfolios.
The first portfolio he looked at was a
portfolio made up of mega cap and large
cap longs versus mega cap and large cap
shorts.
And the second model portfolio that he
looked at was a model portfolio that was
made up of mid cap longs versus large cap
shorts.
And our example that was shown in the
spreadsheet video.
The portfolio that had selected mid cap
longs versus large cap shorts outperformed
the portfolio with mega cap and large cap
longs versus mega cap and large cap
shorts.
And part of the reason why Chris showed
you that at this stage in the video series
is because this is what typically happens
in a GDP growth environment.
So, in the majority of times when GDP is
growing.
This is because in a GDP growth
environment, the sensitivity of mid cap
earnings is higher than the sensitivity of
mega cap and large cap stocks earnings to
the business cycle.
So, in a GDP growth environment, every
unit of growth that we get in the economy
translates into a higher increase in the
earnings of mid cap stocks on average
relative to mega cap and large cap stocks
earnings.
And of course, the reverse is true on
average when we have GDP contraction.
But we showed you this example in the
spreadsheet video at this stage because
it's useful to do so as for most of the
time economies are in a state of GDP
growth.
And, of course, this is not a hard and
fast rule that this just always happens
where all mid caps outperform all mega
caps and large caps all the time when the
economy is growing.
Of course, that's not the case.
And, of course, you actually have to be
able to select the right mid cap longs and
the right mega cap and large cap shorts in
order to make money.
And this comes with the quality of your
trade idea generation process, the quality
of your trade ideas.
And we'll be moving into that section of
the PTM video series next.
But, as a recap, at this stage for
portfolio modeling, just remember to be
using the non-rebalanced portfolio method
on a regular basis and also utilizing the
CEW method for quick answers on
outperformance and underperformance for
two stocks and for portfolios.
For portfolios for modeling portfolios.
So you have the download there for
portfolio modeling and you can utilize
that now forever.
Now, the next thing that Chris showed you
were all of the resources and processes
for calculating portfolio volatility.
So, back to the basics, the variability in
your portfolio is the volatility of your
portfolio and therefore it represents the
risk and opportunity of your portfolio.
So, like any single asset such as a stock
where we can calculate volatility,
portfolio volatility can be calculated as
well.
And portfolios like stocks can be high
risk, low risk or medium risk.
Therefore, with exposure to portfolios
similar to exposure to a single asset like
a stock.
We can choose the level of risk that we
actually want to have in a portfolio.
Similar to the way we can choose the level
of risk that we want in a single asset
like a stock.
So, if we choose the level of risk that we
want in a portfolio, we would get a higher
expected return from higher risk
portfolios versus a lower expected return
from lower risk portfolios.
So, the upside and the downside is greater
in risky portfolios versus low risk
portfolios.
Now, in terms of our volatility
calculation methods, the most common
volatility measure is a statistical
calculation of standard deviation.
This is very similar to the distribution
of returns method that we've looked at
previously when we look at realized or
historical volatility in terms of a
calculation.
So, we're utilizing the same methods that
we use for single assets to actually
calculate portfolio volatility.
And if you recall, Chris modeled two
portfolios, portfolio one long mega cap
and large cap stocks versus short mega cap
and large cap stocks.
And portfolio two long mid caps versus
short large caps.
And portfolio two on average has more
volatility.
Therefore, it has more risk and
opportunity.
And when we're modeling portfolio
volatility for us to get an expectation of
future volatility, we are using historical
asset prices to work out variance,
covariance, and then apply weightings for
each stock in the portfolio.
And there's plenty of resources in terms
of background reading.
There's the basic statistics guide that
you can go through to bring you up to
speed.
There's the IPLT video series, which is
very good background information for
applying the portfolio volatility
calculation methods.
And of course, there's video 19 of the PTM
video series.
Now, what does this mean for us as traders
and portfolio managers?
It's all very well being able to calculate
everything.
But in terms of the interpretation and on
an ongoing basis, how we use this.
Remember, we build long short portfolios,
not long only portfolios.
And there's two main reasons that we build
long short portfolios.
Firstly, we want to make money when the
market goes up and when it goes down.
So that is our absolute return mandate.
This is our opportunity.
Secondly, we have diversification.
So for diversification purposes, we have
preemptive risk management measures in
place.
And this is our risk.
So we want to make sure that when we are
wrong on a position, which is inevitably
going to happen frequently throughout our
careers,
that not one single position can kill us
or wipe us out.
We have to diversify enough to a point
where we're not being stupid or too
concentrated in our positioning.
So taking too much risk.
But we don't want to be too diverse that
we can't make high returns.
So we're not exposing ourselves to
potential large upside in our returns.
So in terms of volatility, in terms of
risk and opportunity, as traders and
portfolio managers, we are always walking
this tightrope.
What we need to do is target a level of
risk that we want to take in order to get
the returns we are seeking.
And this is sometimes referred to in
theoretical finance as the efficient
frontier.
When it comes to portfolio volatility and
what we require as traders and portfolio
managers,
part of the reason that we approach the
market with a long short portfolio mandate
is because it lowers portfolio volatility.
So we always have two competing factors to
consider.
We have our desire to get outsized
absolute returns.
Our desire for opportunity.
But we also have our desire to control
risks.
So our desire to make sure that we're not
being reckless.
So we choose the level of annual risk that
we want to take.
And we target an annual expected return
from that risk.
And this gives us our target for our sharp
ratio, which when it's reported at the end
of the year is your annual return divided
by the annual standard deviation of your
portfolio.
So divided by the volatility of your
And this, of course, is all in the context
of our mandate.
We aim to maximize our sharp ratio and
make money regardless of whether the
market goes up or down.
We always want to be targeting a return
where we do way better than the stock
market in both up and down markets.
We don't benchmark ourselves versus stock
market returns.
We just want to make as much money as
possible.
Our absolute return mandate in both up and
down markets.
We want to maximize our sharp.
But, of course, we always want to be doing
way better than stock market returns.
So when it comes to the portfolio
volatility spreadsheet, the resources, you
can use the portfolio volatility
calculator in conjunction with the
portfolio modeling spreadsheet.
We use the modeling spreadsheet for
backtesting performance and for current
and intended portfolios.
And we use the portfolio volatility
calculator to make sure that we're
building portfolios with a high enough
level of volatility to enable outsized
returns and that are diverse enough to
enable sensible risk management.
So we're looking to be at the efficient
frontier and we're looking to have a high
enough level of volatility to get outsized
returns.
Now, of course, there's an overlap between
video 18 portfolio volatility and video 19
portfolio correlation.
There's two core factors that affect a
portfolio's volatility.
Firstly, the volatility of the assets in
the portfolio.
And secondly, the correlations between
those assets.
And when Chris was going through this and
teaching you how to calculate portfolio
correlation, he posed a very simple
question.
How much do each of these factors actually
affect the volatility of the portfolio?
And the answer was, well, it depends on
the size of the portfolio.
So the amount of positions, because as
assets are added to the portfolio, as long
as the correlation between those assets is
less than one,
the volatility of the portfolio falls
quite significantly the more positions
that you add.
And the lower the correlation, the more
efficient the diversification actually
becomes and the faster risk of the
portfolio decreases.
And if you recall our visualization where
we're comparing different portfolios with
different correlations,
if you recall the blue and the orange
portfolios that Chris used as his example,
we looked at the blue and orange
portfolios starting at one position and
they both have the same volatility at the
point of origin.
And as assets were added to the
portfolios, the volatility of the orange
line portfolio decreased at a much faster
rate
because the correlation of the correlation
of the assets in that portfolio was lower
at 0.2 versus 0.45 for the blue line
portfolio.
So when we have small portfolios where we
just have one or a few positions, the
volatility of those individual assets is
the most important thing.
So their contribution to the P&L outcome
of the portfolio is high.
However, in larger portfolios.
So when we're talking about portfolios
where we have, say, eight to 12 positions.
So a typical long short retail trader
portfolio, it's the correlation values of
the assets to each other that matters much
more.
Additionally, something else that was
covered in the portfolio correlation
video, and it's very important to
understand this when it comes to
diversification.
Chris posed the question, is it wise to
simply keep adding positions to a
portfolio to diversify?
And the answer is, of course not, for two
reasons.
Firstly, the marginal reduction in
portfolio risk above this gate or
parameter of eight to 12 positions.
The marginal reduction in the portfolio
risk above that is small or non-existent.
So there is a decreasing benefit beyond a
certain point for diversification.
This is what we call in the industry over
diversification.
Secondly, we don't want to compromise ever
the quality of our trade ideas.
Realistically, you simply can't come up
with an ever increasing amount or infinite
amount of high quality trade ideas.
The more you diversify, the likelihood is
that the quality of trade ideas is going
to decrease.
Therefore, we end up lowering our expected
portfolio return.
So this is where things start to neatly
come together.
We have our two competing factors where we
are also always walking a tightrope.
So we have our requirement for outsized
absolute returns.
And we also have our requirement, our
desire to control risks sensibly.
So we have our desire for opportunity and
our desire to control risks.
And we're always looking to maintain that
balance.
So with this in mind and this level of
understanding, we can now look at
efficient retail trader portfolios and
what they look like.
And if you've done the IPLT video series,
you will have seen these slides before in
the IPLT video series.
But that was a basic level of
understanding.
This is now a much deeper level of
So at the retail trading level, we have
different sizes of trading accounts,
different levels of margin capital.
So retail traders with small levels of
margin capital of $25,000, $50,000,
$100,000 on margin.
Where are they existing?
Well, typically at any one moment in time,
they'll be running long short portfolios
with 8 to 12 positions.
For retail traders with larger levels of
margin capital of say $250,000, $500,000
or $1,000,000 on margin.
We become slightly more diversified, but
not by much.
So at this level, there's an overlap with
smaller levels of margin capital.
We'll have 10 positions at the low end,
but on the higher end, we would have up to
14 positions.
And yes, the marginal reduction in risk is
small at the portfolio level.
But if we have more positions, we're less
likely to be in a situation where one
position can significantly reduce our
returns if it goes wrong.
When we move on to higher levels of
capital, so we're talking very big retail
traders, which is very rare.
But retail traders with professional
levels of margin capital, we're talking $2
million to $5 million on margin.
The amount of positions in our portfolio
increases to a gate or parameter of 12 to
16 positions.
Now, in different parts of the world,
retail traders have availability to
different financial products.
So we look at the world as the United
States and the rest of the world.
And we look at the financial products, the
instruments that are available to retail
traders in the United States
and retail traders outside the US in the
rest of the world.
So if we look at the bottom of the screen,
we have three examples, which if you've
done the IPLT video series, you will have
seen before.
But now you'll have a better understanding
of what's going on.
We have our three examples of retail
traders.
Firstly, on the left hand side, we have
our US equity options trader that has
between $25,000 and $2 million margin
capital.
We have our outside the United States or
rest of world contracts for difference CFD
portfolio manager or trader.
So that case, that case, that example has
the same amount of margin capital in their
account.
And then we also have thirdly, the US
based retail trader.
So a long short stock trader that has
$25,000 to $2 million margin.
So all of these examples of retail
traders, whether it's in the US or the
rest of the world, they all have the same
amount of margin.
They are in the gate or parameter of
$25,000 to $2 million on margin.
The difference between the three in the
assumptions that we're making is the
financial instruments and the leverage
that they're using.
Something else that stays the same across
these three examples is the annual
volatility of the underlying portfolio.
And the gate or parameter we're using here
is between 15% and 30% expected annual
portfolio volatility.
So it's the same amount of margin, same
amount of margin capital for every case
and the same amount of expected annual
portfolio volatility in the underlying
stock portfolio.
The only difference is the assumption of
the financial instruments that are
available to these retail traders.
So let's start at the bottom left of the
screen and start looking at the risk and
return for a portfolio for a US equity
options trader.
We have our 15 to 30% expected annual
portfolio volatility in the underlying
stock portfolio.
So the 30% number, you know, to be around
30% or close to that in a well diversified
8 to 12 position portfolio is a challenge.
It's quite difficult.
30% annualized portfolio volatility is
difficult to get with diversification.
But if we can get 15%, 17 and a half
percent, 20%, 22 and a half percent,
something like this.
If we can be in the lower end of the
range, but have a sensible level of
volatility.
If we can target that, this is a good
level of portfolio volatility to target.
It's a good level of risk to take and
presents us with ample opportunity to make
outsized returns.
Now for the US equity options trader,
because this trader is utilizing options,
they have implicit leverage through
options positioning of anything between
three to 10 times.
10 times what the underlying volatility of
the portfolio is.
So this gives us a range of possible
outcomes in terms of annual return of 45%
on the low end and 300% on the high end.
So this gives us a range of results.
But realistically, we want to be targeting
a number that is very achievable.
We target 50 to 100% annual return when we
are utilizing equity options.
And of course, there's no cap on the
returns here.
The returns can be higher, but we just
want to be realistic here.
And remember, we're not looking at this
and saying we want to make a specific
return or a specific amount.
What we're doing here is that we're
looking at ranges.
And if we can fall somewhere between those
ranges, we've done a very good job.
So with our implicit leverage over many
trades of between three to 10 times the
underlying portfolio volatility, if we can
just be at the lower end and we get a
sharp ratio of 3.3 times, we're going to
land somewhere between 50 and 100%.
So in this instance, let's say, for
example, you put $50,000 in a trading
account.
If the volatility or standard deviation,
the annual standard deviation of your
portfolio is around, say, 17.5% and you're
utilizing options over the entire year and
you achieve a 3.3 times return.
So you get a sharp ratio of 3.3 times out
of that risk.
You're going to achieve around 59, 60%
return, even when you've got a well
diversified long short portfolio.
Now, again, when it comes to a portfolio
correlation, we are again targeting a gate
or a range parameters.
We are not targeting an absolute specific
number for correlation.
We just want to be dropping within a
sensible range.
And the range we want to be dropping in is
the positive 0.3 to negative 0.3 range.
And this is the same for all examples
here, not just for the US equity options
trader.
And what also applies to all of our trader
examples here is these returns are
regardless of the equity market going up
or down.
So this is our absolute return mandate and
it applies to all traders in all regions
of the world, regardless of access to
financial instruments.
But it just so happens that rest of world,
so retail traders outside the United
States, rest of world retail traders can
access US equity options and build and run
US equity options portfolios.
Of course, if you want to learn options
strategies, options trading strategies,
this is taught in our professional options
trading masterclass.
And that is an entire video series in
itself.
What's important here is to really
understand the processes of calculating
the underlying stock portfolio volatility.
And then we apply the financial
instruments that we have access to, to the
volatility of that portfolio.
Where we have differences in access for
retail traders in terms of financial
instruments is that US based retail
traders can no longer access contracts for
difference or CFDs.
So they can't build CFD portfolios.
Only retail traders outside the United
States have access to contracts for
difference and can build CFD portfolios.
So what are contracts for difference?
Well, they are just derivative instruments
that are supposed to mirror one for one
the underlying stock performance.
But as their derivative instruments, they
enable retail traders to get leverage to
the performance of the underlying stocks.
So essentially, it's the same as running a
long short stock portfolio, one for one,
but with leverage, the performance is
leveraged.
So if we look at the CFD portfolio
example, we have the same level of
capital.
We're dealing with the same parameters
here as the equity options portfolio,
where we have between $25,000 and $2
million of margin capital.
So this case, this example is falling in
the same gate, same parameters for margin
capital and also falling into the same
parameters for expected annual volatility.
But in this instance, we are using direct
leverage with CFDs, not implied leverage
like with options.
So with CFDs, a typical situation is that
you'll have a margin trading account that
provides four times leverage, which gives
us a range of possible outcomes when it
comes to annual return.
So you'll have an annual return of
somewhere between 60% and 120%.
However, we need to be more realistic here
for a couple of reasons when it comes to
an annual return number that we are
targeting.
So we target between 22.5% to 45% annual
return when utilizing equity CFDs.
So we apply a minimum Sharpe ratio of 1.5%
on to the volatility of the portfolio,
which gives us our expected target annual
return of the 22.5% to 45%.
So we set a very low expectation for our
Sharpe ratio.
So the return that we get out of the
volatility of the portfolio.
So a Sharpe ratio of 1.5% is pretty much
the minimally acceptable Sharpe ratio in
terms of the return that you get out of
the volatility that you're exposed to.
And this gives us a very realistic number
for annual return of between 22.5% and
45%.
Now, the main reason we have a realistic
annual return expectation that is lower
for a CFD portfolio, a long short CFD
portfolio versus an equity options
portfolio is because with equity options,
we can get more leverage via implied
leverage versus a CFD portfolio.
With CFD portfolio.
With CFD portfolios, the leverage is fixed
at four times.
With equity options portfolios, it's not
fixed.
But typically, you can get anything
between three and 10 times implied
leverage, which naturally increases our
range of possible outcomes to the upside.
Additionally, options portfolios have a
different risk profile dollar for dollar
compared to a CFD portfolio or even a
stock portfolio.
This is because the downside for going
long call options to express a long
position or going long put options to
express a short position is limited to the
amount of premium that you spend on the
option.
Whereas in a CFD portfolio.
Whereas in a CFD portfolio, the amount of
margin that is utilized in a trading
account towards a long position, the
amount of money that can be lost is
greater than the amount that is utilized
from the margin for that position.
And on short CFD positions.
And on short CFD positions, the amount of
downside is unlimited.
The amount of dollar downside is unlimited
on shorts.
So the difference in expected return comes
from the fact that we are using direct
leverage instead of implied leverage via
options.
Our direct leverage with a CFD portfolio
and even a stock portfolio is fixed.
And also options actually change the risk
dynamic of a portfolio because of limited
downside on long options positions.
Now, remember the portfolio, even for the
rest of world CFD portfolio is the same as
the underlying portfolio with the trader
who's utilizing equity options.
It has the same dynamics.
So we have the same expected annual
volatility.
We have the same correlation also.
So our correlation is positive 0.3 to
negative 0.3.
We also have the same level of margin
capital and we have the same absolute
return mandate.
So again, these outcomes are regardless of
the equity market going up or down.
Now, if we look at the exact same
portfolio in the US as a stock portfolio.
So a long short stock portfolio and not a
CFD portfolio.
And the reason we're looking at a long
short stock portfolio in the US is because
US retail traders can't trade CFDs.
So they can only trade long and short
stock positions with two times leverage or
50% margin requirement.
So we have the same level of capital.
So the range of $25,000 to $2 million of
margin capital.
We have the same expected annual portfolio
volatility parameters of 15 to 30%.
And we have the same target portfolio
correlation of 0.3 to minus 0.3.
So we have exactly the same portfolio as
the rest of world CFD trader.
But now we're modeling it as a US based
retail trader that can only take long and
short stock positions on a trading account
that only provides two times leverage.
So on direct leverage of two times, this
gives us a range of possible outcomes for
annual return of 30 to 60%.
But in order to get that return to full
within those parameters, because of the
leverage situation, US based retail
traders, when they're trading long short
stock portfolios, have to be much better
traders than a rest of world CFD portfolio
in order to get the same return.
So we're applying a sharp ratio of 2 here
instead of 1.5, which means a US based
long short portfolio manager, US based
retail trader that's taking the same
approach has to be much better at limiting
losses and much better at maximizing
profits.
So they get a higher return for every unit
of risk.
of risk out of the portfolio.
So guys, when we think of these examples
and when we think of portfolio modeling,
portfolio volatility, portfolio
correlation and our processes that we go
through, we have to think about it in the
context of what financial instruments are
available to us and the size of our margin
capital as well.
Of course, if you want to learn how to
trade equity options and build equity
options portfolios, we are early on in
your education at this stage.
And it's definitely possible, but there's
a lot more work to do.
Retail traders in the US and retail
traders outside the US in the rest of the
world can access US equity options.
That's not a problem.
But at this moment in time, at this point
in your education and for the purposes of
the PTM video series for our learning
curve, we are assuming we are taking the
approach of long short equity stock or CFD
portfolio managers.
Because what's important at this stage is
understanding portfolio modeling,
portfolio volatility, how to calculate it,
portfolio correlation and how everything
ties together and in the context of
trading accounts and in the real world,
what financial instruments are available
to you.
But if you don't understand.
But if you don't understand anything, so
you don't understand portfolio modeling,
volatility for portfolios, correlation of
assets in portfolios, if you don't
understand any of that, having access to
financial instruments is just irrelevant.
So you have to learn all of this stuff
first.
So this is how it all fits together.
Now, in terms of efficient retail trader
portfolios, you absolutely always have to
remember not to forego the quality of your
trade ideas.
So you should always attempt to fall
within the gates or parameters of
efficient retail trader portfolios, but
with high quality trade ideas driven by
fundamentals and catalysts within the 20
to 60 day time horizon.
Use the spreadsheets to estimate
volatility correlation and forecasted
returns based on shop ratio and leverage
that's available or implied leverage via
options.
And you do not have to be ridiculously
accurate all of the time.
You are a retail trader.
Don't get lost in endless rabbit holes of
calculating portfolio volatility and
correlation and forget about your time
horizon.
Forget about trade ideas.
Forget about fundamentals and catalysts.
Don't get lost in endless rabbit holes.
Time is obviously an issue for retail
traders.
So you have to work smart and not hard.
Please do that.
If you're falling within the gates or
parameters to target 50 to 100% return
with 8 to 12 high quality long or short
positions.
So you have a diverse portfolio on a solid
risk adjusted basis.
So sharp ratio with some leverage.
You are exposing yourself to the efficient
frontier.
Don't forgo high quality trade idea
generation for the sake of
diversification.
You have to have both.
Now what you also have to remember is that
all of the stuff that you've learned up to
this point and all of the stuff that
you're going to do in the future in terms
of your processes.
This is going to give you an edge.
99% of retail traders are never going to
do any of this.
And all the stuff that you've just learned
in this section of the video series when
it comes to portfolio modeling, portfolio
volatility, portfolio correlation, and
even beta.
If you are seeking to go into the industry
as a professional trader, a basic
understanding of how all of this works is
absolutely necessary.
It's what you would learn in your first
one to two years as a graduate out of
university entering hedge funds and
investment banks, and especially at hedge
funds as a junior portfolio manager.
Now, as we were discussing portfolio
correlation, we obviously took a slight
detour there to talk about efficient
retail trader portfolios.
And I wanted to do that at this stage
because it shows you how everything fits
together at this point in your learning
curve and also primes you and gets you
ready for the next stage of the video
series, which will be trade idea
generation.
Just knowing at this stage how things fit
together in the bigger picture will give
you a lot more clarity as to the reasons
why we do certain things in the way we do
it in the trade idea generation process.
But for the moment, let's go back to some
of the specifics of portfolio correlation.
If you recall, Chris also showed you how
to use the spreadsheets and showed you how
to calculate correlation, how to create a
time series of correlation.
So how correlation goes up and down over
time and also how to model different
portfolios based on market capitalization.
So if you recall, Chris went through an
example of a 10 stock portfolio where we
had six mid cap longs and four large cap
shorts.
And this portfolio showed high efficiency
of both correlation and volatility.
Now, just as a reminder, we always have
our two competing factors to consider.
So firstly, our desire to get outsized
absolute returns, which is our
opportunity.
And secondly, our desire to control risks,
which of course is our risk profile.
So we choose the level of annual risk that
we want to take and we target an annual
expected return from that risk.
So we're seeking a tidy, efficient, sharp
ratio.
So if you target the 15 to 30% gate for
the underlying stock portfolio volatility
and you take some market risk as well,
and you achieve a decent, sharp ratio,
utilizing some leverage, as long as your
ideas are high quality,
and you are going to do very well over
many trades over a long period of time.
And you'll notice with Chris's example
where we have the mid cap longs, the six
mid cap longs and the four shorts,
the four large cap shorts that we're now
looking to assume in model portfolios,
some sort of market risk.
Having some level of market risk is
acceptable.
So yes, we aim to get the highest amount
of return possible from the lowest amount
of acceptable risk that's possible.
So again, we are choosing that level of
volatility that's high enough to get
outsized returns, but not too high that
we're being irresponsible.
And we are happy to accept some market
risk.
So we're looking to maximize our sharp
ratio and we have an absolute return
mandate.
So we're looking to make money regardless
of whether the market goes up or down.
And this example portfolio is a good segue
into the next area that we're going to
look at, which is portfolio beta, because
now we're assuming some market risk.
So when it comes to the portfolio
volatility and correlation spreadsheet
download, obviously there is overlap
between the correlation video and the
portfolio volatility video.
And the resources are very similar.
The spreadsheet's the same, except
correlation has been added to the
portfolio volatility spreadsheet.
So in your ongoing processes, you're going
to use it in the same way, except now
correlation has been added.
So use the portfolio volatility and
correlation spreadsheet to make sure that
you're building portfolios with a high
enough level of volatility to enable
outsized returns and that are diverse
enough to enable sensible risk management.
And of course, when it comes to
correlation, make sure that your portfolio
correlation lands within the gates or
parameters of acceptable correlation of
positive 0.3 to negative 0.3.
Now, when it comes to portfolio beta, the
next video that Chris Quill took you
through.
So even though we run long short
portfolios as traders and portfolio
managers, we have to be willing to accept
at any one moment in time, some market
risk.
Beta calculations at the stock level and
the portfolio level, they help us to
understand at any one moment in time, what
exposure we have to market risk in our
portfolio.
We can be close to market neutral.
And this can theoretically occur through
beta adjustments of portfolios.
However, we have to be realistic here.
Being completely market neutral at any one
moment in time is not just close to
impossible.
It's probably impossible.
Not only that, we are risk takers.
We are traders and portfolio managers.
It's also undesirable for us as traders
and portfolio managers to always be market
neutral.
We want to be accepting some market risk.
Additionally, we have to be very mindful
of what beta actually is and its
calculation.
Beta is always changing.
And that's why Chris gave you the analysis
and the capability now of calculating
rolling beta.
If we wanted to be market neutral all the
time as portfolio managers, we would have
to readjust every day to be close to
perfect beta hedged portfolios.
And it's not just impractical for us to do
that and especially for you to do that as
retail traders.
It's not just impractical, but beta also
has its flaws.
Beta is always changing.
So one of the weaknesses of beta, one of
the flaws is that we're using past data.
It is all based on past data and past
relationships.
Okay.
Our assumptions can cause us to create
blind spots in our risk.
So we can be thinking that if we're beta
market neutral, for example, we can be
thinking that we've eliminated market risk
when we actually really haven't.
The numbers may not be telling the truth
of what's actually occurring in the market
at the time.
Or things can actually change or change
drastically in the market.
And everything in the past is now
irrelevant.
And I can tell you now that even in
professional circles, in professional
trading circles, beta and reliance on its
assumptions can create blind spots and
complacency in risk calculations.
And it can even be abused to hide real
risks.
So we must be aware of it.
And we must use the processes to calculate
our beta adjusted risk in stock
portfolios.
But we must be also aware of its drawbacks
and its flaws.
And we must be intellectually honest with
ourselves that we are calculating
accurately.
So we try to get the most accurate
reflection of the current reality of the
world.
And with our own mandate of our absolute
return mandate, where we want to make
outsized returns on the way up and
outsized returns on the way down.
We have to just admit to ourselves.
And we have to just accept some level of
market risk.
So especially for retail traders on
smaller accounts, we have to accept that
we need some level of market risk in our
portfolios at any one moment in time.
In order to expose ourselves to potential
outsized returns.
We need some level of market risk.
We need some level of market risk in our
portfolios all the time.
It's not only an impossible task.
We can get close to it.
But it's almost impossible, if not
impossible, to always be perfectly market
neutral.
Not only that, but it's also not required
for traders and portfolio managers,
especially at the retail level.
We want some but not too much market risk
in our portfolios.
So for retail traders, beta modeling
should be used as a tool to get a snapshot
of what level of market risk that you're
exposed to at any one moment in time.
So you're aware of it and you're happy
with it and you're happy that it aligns
with your current macroeconomic views at
the time.
You should be using it also to model any
portfolio changes that you're considering.
So when you're thinking about adding in
new long and or new short ideas to a
portfolio and how it's going to affect
your market risk and whether this still
aligns with your views.
Additionally, you're going to be using
beta modeling all the time to understand
the actual contribution on a beta adjusted
basis of each individual asset in the
portfolio to the outcome of the portfolio
and that you're comfortable with it.
But the most important thing is your net
long or short bias in your portfolio
overall.
So if you want to be net long in your
portfolio, but when you're beta modeling
your portfolio with reasonable
assumptions,
you realize that you're actually beta flat
or neutral or even beta short or even just
not long enough,
then you probably want to adjust your
portfolio to get longer.
So it aligns with your market view.
And on the flip side, if you actually want
to be net short in your portfolio,
but when you're going through your beta
modeling and you're using reasonable
assumptions,
you realize that you're actually either
beta neutral or beta net long or you're
just not short enough,
then of course, you probably want to think
about or actually adjusting your portfolio
to get shorter.
So when it comes to portfolio beta, again,
we are walking a tightrope here with beta
as traders and portfolio managers.
We always have our two competing factors
to consider our desire to get outsized
absolute returns.
So our opportunity and our desire to
control risks.
So our risk, we want to be exposing
ourselves to a beta adjusted sensible
level of market risk in our portfolios at
any one moment in time.
Use the beta sheets to calculate stock and
portfolio beta and understand what your
market risk is at any one moment in time.
And you need to make sure that your beta
adjusted net long or net short exposure
roughly aligns with your market view.
And again, it doesn't have to be 100%
accurate.
You just have to be roughly aligned.
Remember, you're a retail trader.
Most retail traders, 99% of them will
never, ever be doing what you're doing.
You're already ahead if you're doing this.
Just don't get lost in endless rabbit
holes of calculating portfolio volatility,
correlation and beta.
Time is obviously an issue.
So please work smart and not hard.
So when it comes to beta risk and
opportunity.
When we're targeting the gate, the 15 to
30% underlying stock portfolio volatility,
and then we add in some market risk.
We are attempting to achieve a decent shop
ratio and utilize some leverage.
Obviously, if we add in beta modeling to
our portfolio and we accept some market
risk and we're on top of it.
As long as our ideas are high quality,
we're going to stand a very good chance at
getting outsized returns in all market
conditions.
So the question, what's an acceptable
level of market risk at any one time in
the portfolio?
Well, again, we use gates here.
So running a beta net long or short
portfolio exposure of within plus and
minus 30% at any one moment in time is
totally okay.
But that is, of course, assuming that
you've actually done your macroeconomic
work that we covered in the first part of
the video series.
And that your positions are well thought
out.
So high quality trade ideas that have gone
through the entire trade idea generation
process that we're going to go through in
the next stage.
And the market risk exposure that you've
taken in your portfolio actually
represents your macro view.
So, guys, we've covered a lot of ground
here.
So let's let's summarize and conclude and
overlap all the work that we've done so
far, how it all fits in.
We just conquered a major part of the
scientific art of trading and portfolio
management.
And yes, admittedly, it is a lot of work
and it's difficult for most people to get
their head around initially.
So fortunately or unfortunately, depending
on how you look at it, in order for you as
a retail trader to climb the competency
hierarchy,
this is the groundwork you need to know
and that you have to incorporate into your
regular processes.
The previous four videos that were taken
by Chris Quill are a fantastic example of
the differences between unconscious
competence.
So the level that professional traders are
operating at and unconscious incompetence,
the level at the vast majority of retail
traders are operating at.
Your job as a professional trader or even
a retail trader that's operating in the
retail infrastructure, but trading at a
professional level.
Your job is not just to make money on one
or two big trades, then disappear and then
come back to play at the casino in a year
or two when you just feel like it, when
you have a whim.
This is a fairy tale in the trading
industry and the vast majority of people
that engage in that behavior will always
blow up.
Your job is to make money consistently
over thousands of career trades over many
years and how you make your money is also
super important.
So you have to not only make consistent
money, but you also have to make it
efficiently.
And that's why we measure not just
returns, but risk adjusted returns.
You are running a business and the
business requires process, dedication,
time management and statistical awareness
of how the business works.
And we will later in the video series be
extending this analysis into statistics
and into risk management.
So the foundations of portfolio management
section of the PTM video series that
you've just experienced overlaps with risk
management and trader statistics that
we're going to be looking at later in the
video series.
And now what we're going to be doing is
we're going to be moving on to trade idea
generation.
So as mentioned previously, modeling
portfolio performance, modeling
volatility, correlation and beta, it's all
well and good.
But if the trade ideas that you put into
this mechanism, into this business are not
high quality, it's all just pointless.
You absolutely need both.
The inventory that you're running, the
inventory of your trade ideas that you're
running at any one moment in time are your
oxygen as a trader.
Everything else is statistical processing
and rigor.
It's mechanical.
The trade idea generation process does
also require statistical processing and
rigor, but it also requires lateral
thinking, creativity, imagination and a
lot of common sense.
Without a trader having a constant stream
of high quality trade ideas, you will just
suffocate and die.
Trade ideas are your oxygen as a trader.
So we're now going to move on to the most
important stage of the PTM video series,
the bottom up fundamental trade idea
generation.
And we're going to start with quantitative
processing, then move on to qualitative
processing and catalysts.
So let's get stuck into it, guys, and I'll
see you back at the desk in the next
video.